right now
there is an aspiring teacher
who is working on a 60-page paper
based on some age-old education theory
developed by some dead education
professor
wondering to herself what this task that
she's engaging in
has to do with what she wants to do with
her life
which is be an educator
change lives and spark magic
right now
there is
an aspiring teacher in a graduate school
of education
who's watching a professor babel on and
on about engagement
in the most disengaging way possible
right now
there's a first year teacher at home
who is pouring through lesson plans
trying to make sense of standards
who's trying to make sense of how to
grade students appropriately while at
the same time saying to herself over and
over again don't smile till november
because that's what she was taught in
her teacher education program
right now
there is a student who is coming up with
a way to convince his mom or dad
that he's very very sick and can't make
it to school tomorrow
on the other hand right now
there are amazing educators that are
sharing information information that's
shared in such a beautiful way that the
students are sitting at the edge of
their seats just waiting for a bead of
sweat to drop off the face of this
person so they can soak up all that
knowledge
right now
there is also a person who has an entire
audience wrapped up attention
a person that's weaving a powerful
narrative about a world
that the people who are listening have
never imagined or seen before but if
they close their eyes tightly enough
they can envision that world because the
storytelling is so compelling
right now
there's a person who can tell an
audience to put their hands up in the
air and they will stay there until he
says put them down
right now
so people will then say well chris
you describe the guy who's going through
some awful training but you're also
describing these powerful educators if
you're thinking about the world of
education or urban education in
particular these guys will probably
cancel each other out and then we'll be
okay
the reality is the folks are described
as the master teachers the master
narrative builders the master
storytellers are far removed from
classrooms
the folks who know the skills about how
to teach and engage in an audience don't
even know what teacher certification
means
they may not even have the degrees
to be able to have
anything to call an education
and that to me is sad
it's sad because the people who i
described they were very disinterested
in the learning process want to be
effective teachers but they have no
models i'm going to paraphrase mark
twain mark twain says that proper
preparation or teaching
is so powerful that it can turn bad
morals to good it can turn awful
practice into powerful ones it can
change men and transform them into
angels
the folks who i described earlier
got proper preparation and teaching
not in any college or university but by
virtue of just being in the same spaces
of those who engage
guess where those places are
barber shops
rap concerts
and most importantly in the black church
and i've been framing this idea called
pentecostal pedagogy who here has been
to a black church
you got a couple hands
to go to a black church that preacher
starts off and he realizes that he has
to engage the audience so he starts off
with this sort of word play in the
beginning often times and then he takes
a pause and he says oh my gosh they're
not quite paying attention so he says
can i get an amen
so can i get it amen
and all of a sudden everybody's reawoken
that preacher bangs on the pulpit for
attention he he drops his voice at a
very very low volume when he wants
people to key into him and those things
are the skills that we need for the most
engaging teachers
so why does teacher education only give
you theory and theory and and tell you
about standards and tell you about all
these things that have nothing to do
with the basic skills that magic that
you need to engage an audience to engage
a student so i make the argument that we
reframe teacher education that we could
focus on content and that's fine and we
can focus on theories and that's fine
but content and theories with the
absence of the magic
of teaching and learning
means nothing now people oftentimes say
well magic is just magic you know
they're teachers who despite all their
challenges who had those skills get into
those schools and they're able to engage
in the audience and and the
administrative walks by and says wow
he's so good i wish all my teachers
could be that good and and when they try
to describe what that is they just say
he has that magic
but i'm here to tell you that magic can
be taught
magic can be taught
magic can be taught now how do you teach
it
you teach it by allowing people to go
into those spaces where the magic is
happening if you want to be an aspiring
teacher in urban education you got to
leave the confines of that university
and go into the hood
you got to go in there and hang out at
the barber shop you got to attend that
black church and you got to view those
folks that have the power to engage and
just take notes on what they do
in our teacher education classes in my
university i've started a project where
every single student that comes in there
sits and watches rap concerts
they watch the way that the rappers move
and talk with their hands they they
study the way that he walks proudly
across that stage they listen to his
metaphors and analogies and they start
learning these little things that if
they practice enough becomes the key to
magic they learned that if you just
stare at a student and raise your
eyebrow about a quarter of an inch you
don't have to say a word because they
know that that means that you want more
and if it could transform teacher
education
to focus on teaching teachers how to
create that magic
then
we can make dead classes come alive we
can reignite imaginations and we can
change education thank you
you